public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'ancien premier ministre et futur ex
élu c'est votre choix
jean pierre raffarin et jean pierre
raffarin notre invité bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de
public sénat avec la fp avec radio
classique avec les échos trois questions
vous seront posées ce soir par jean
francis pécresse marques prêts elles et
mickaël szames s d'abord économies
notamment dans l'armée un c'est un point
sensible pour vous un pot réforme le
compte est il bon selon vous après la
volte-face de l'exécutif deuxième
question les constructif et l'air
doivent-ils toujours trainde relais
longs couteaux ou même si l'exclusion ne
semble pas à l'ordre du jour ce soir
troisième question et vous maintenant
jean pierre raffarin et bien vous ne
parlerez tout à l'heure de vos nouveaux
projets ils sont nombreux une fondation
sur laquelle d'ailleurs vous pourrez
lever le voile
quand vous aurez bien sûr rendu votre
mandat de sénateur c'est prévu pour le
mois d'octobre mais d'abord une toute
première question d'actualité
[Musique]
la route semble se dégager mais on peut
le dire elle se dégage pour paris 2024
avec la notion de la double attribution
à 2024 2028 qui a été approuvé tout à
l'heure par le cio à lausanne où la
france a donc présenté son grand oral
emmanuel macron en tête il l'a dit le
chef de l'état la france est prête pour
les jeux elle les attend est ce que vous
aussi vous les attendez oui c'est une
nouvelle bonsoir michel grossiord
bonsoir à toutes et à tous
je suis heureux de participer à cette
dernière émission en tout cas pour vous
de la saison pour moi dans ce statut est
de pouvoir répondre ainsi à vos
questions je pense que cette décision
est très importante parce que un nouveau
refus pour paris on aurait été quand
même une insolence
donc il était bien qu' on puisse avoir
cette perspective et je me réjouis que
le président de la république est tenu a
présenté ce projet comme un projet sobre
de jeux olympiques
dans ce contexte là je pense que la
france il ya beaucoup à gagner même s'il
faudra être vigilant sur les coûts alors
il est engagé mais pas que lui on le
voit il ya eu la maire de paris la
présidente de région donc madame hidalgo
madame pécresse
ça montre que en fait toutes les tout le
monde peut se mobilise et vous devez
créer un consensus au delà des
divergences politiques quand un enjeu
capital
je pense qu'on cause l'image de la
france dans le monde c'est quelque chose
de très important parce qu'en font la
france ait une influence plus puissante
que sa seule économie et donc nous avons
besoin de cette image il mâche fondée
par notre place par exemple au conseil
de sécurité à l'onu
donc on a à part notre histoire
évidemment on parle de grand homme par
nos leaders est donc par l'élection d'un
jeune président de la république disons
le clairement l'élection d' emmanuel
macron a été l'occasion de re dynamiser
un peu l'image de la france dans le
monde donc tout ceci est très important
les jeux olympiques y contribuer à
condition aussi que nous tenions compte
de l'air du temps l'air du temps ce
n'est pas la course la puissance la
course à la richesse d'un constat la
démonstration de force
c'est au contraire la sobriété à la
qualité ce soit la reconduction vous
savez bien qu'on n'ait jamais mettre des
dérapages financiers rien
bien sûr mais d'autres villes ont connu
cela je pense d'autres villes en ont
souffert mais je pense que la une paris
de bright innovantes pour essayer de
montrer que l'on peut faire aujourd'hui
les jeux olympiques qui sont autre chose
que la course à aa la démonstration
puissance à 40 la suite de l'épreuve de
vérité tout de suite avec jean francis
pécresse le directeur de la rédaction de
radio classique
[Musique]
michel bonsoir jean pierre raffarin
bonsoir alors le ministre des comptes
publics gérald darmanin a annoncé ce
matin dans le parisien un plan
d'économies de 4 milliards et demi
d'euros sur la seule année 2010 est est
ce que ce compte est ce que le compte de
ces économies vous semble bon d'abord
est ce que vous
je pense qu'il est nécessaire de faire
des économies je pense que ce niveau
d'économies est sans doute à un niveau
plancher
néanmoins je suis très inquiet on joue
en ligue 1 pour un certain nombre de
budget parce que il y a des d'abord des
engagements qui sont pris et puis il ya
des négociations qui doit être mené
vous savez qu'un procédures budgétaires
habituel c'est un ministre qui va
rencontrer le secrétaire d'état au
budget qui explique ces projets le
secrétaire d'état au budget fait une
proposition de budget et si on n'est pas
d'accord on va en arbitrage et le
premier ministre l'a 1
un article de presse annonce des
chiffres en ce qui concerne par exemple
le ministère de la défense s'est
complètement vend pas antagoniste avec
ceux qui ont ce compte était des
décisions du conseil de défense
précédemment on écoute si vous voulez le
ministre des comptes publics justement
il était interrogé ce matin car le
chiffre n'est pas officiel le chiffre
des économies mais il circule
abondamment on écoute ce matin monsieur
leur manager calculé 850 millions
économisés la différence 530 à
l'intérieur 160 à la justice a fait un
milliard et demi à peu près sur ces
trois ministères sensibles rogner sur la
sécurité des français
absolument pas nous avons travaillé avec
monsieur me that ailleurs madame la
ministre de la justice madame la
ministre des armées pour trouver des
économies 850 millions à la défense
on peut dans la période trouvé cette
économie sans fragiliser la protection
des français mais le budget 2010 est de
la défense ne bougera pas ce que je veux
faire comprendre c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'économies sur le budget voté par le
parlement
il y a quand même un gel qui est annoncé
il ya d'abord un gel de crédits
y aura-t-il des gels et là on dépasse le
milliard donc presque à deux et donc là
il ya une vraie question qui est posée
et puis
on voit bien que les engagements du
dernier conseil de défense qui ont été
de nature à redresser la courbe des
investissements militaires
ces engagements la honte il a tenu donc
pour le moment je ne condamne pas mais
je trouve que la démarche est précipitée
et que le parlement ne peut pas accepter
d'être mis devant le fait accompli de
cette nature alors 850 millions d'euros
que ce soit des économies ou un gel il
n'empêche que le résultat est à peu près
le même c'est à dire que les armées
françaises en 2010 elles doivent se
serrer la ceinture
est ce que c'est une faute est ce que
vous est ce que vous considérez en tant
que vous étiez jusqu'à il ya quelques
jours je crois le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères et
des forces armées je le suis encore
aujourd'hui vous n'êtes encore
aujourd'hui ben voilà jusqu'à demain
jusqu'à d'un bon est ce que vous
considérez que c'est une faute c'est une
faute
c'est une faute nous venons de publier
un rapport très clair ici au sénat sur
un objectif de 2% qui correspond aux
engagements du président de la
république pendant sa campagne le drame
du petit bar et ou 2% l'a déjà mentionné
monsieur là c'est pour absolument et
donc cela veut dire grosso modo que il
faut faire un bond de 2 milliards en par
an pour atteindre cet objectif mais il
faut voir d'abord que nous avons plus de
trente mille hommes aujourd'hui engagés
dans des opérations extérieures ce sont
des opérations extrêmement difficile qui
sont épuisantes avec des équipes qui
n'ont pas toujours les moyens de leur
combat et donc il ya sur le plan
matériel comme sur le plan moral
la nécessité de soutenir nos amis et
surtout de leur donner les moyens de nos
ambitions
parce que le pire c'est de leur donner
beaucoup d'ambition et peu de moyens
donc si on réduit les moyens réduisons
les zambiens ont réduit les moyens ce
quelqu un s ont réduit la sécurité ce
qu'on met en péril la sécurité de la
france en tout cas et il est clair qu'on
sera obligé de réduire des opérations
extérieures et la sécurité et met donc
mais donc la sécurité parce que si on
est engagé et c'est pour notre sécurité
et donc si on réduit notre engagement
c'est quand on réduit notre sécurité
donc je pense qu'il y a là un certain
nombre de sujets qui doivent être
débattues je pense
il s'agit là de préannonce que nous
aurons des discussions mais nous avons
entendu la ministre des armées à la
commission du sénat la semaine dernière
je pense qu'elle est déterminée à se
battre dans la ligne de ce que sont les
conseils de défendre un peu plus de dix
engagements du prénom et donc je pense
que là le comme d'habitude bercy lance
ses premiers ses premières salves de
manière à un avenir tout le monde qu'il
faut penser aux économies et puis nous
allons avoir un certain nombre de
négociations
moi ce que je dis c'est qu'un
gouvernement ne peut pas demander à ses
soldats
un niveau d'intervention aussi fort que
maintenant sans leur donner les moyens
de ses interventions
est-ce que vous en est ce que vous en a
appelé solennellement au président de la
république et le chef des armées pour le
dire ne touchez pas au budget de la
sécurité nationale française nous avons
été voir le président de la république
pour lui donner nos propositions et nous
avons cru comprendre qu'il avait une
réaction positive à nos propositions
nous sommes dans un processus qui vient
de s'engager
nous voterons le budget à la fin de
l'année 2010 est donc il y encore des
négociations donc je ne mets pas le
couteau sous la gorge à quiconque
aujourd'hui mais je dis que clairement
nous ne pouvons pas donner à nos soldats
des missions sans leur donner les moyens
de ses missions vous ne me laissez ces
sujets là c'est une question d'éthique
de responsabilité pour les élus du
peuple pour les dirigeants de ce pays
on n'envoie pas des soldats au feu si on
leur donne pas les moyens d'assumer
leurs responsabilités mais les
assurances que vous aviez reçu du
président de la république lui même
c'était le 20 juin vous étiez dans son
bureau
absolument elles se sont envolées
écoutez nous sommes dans un processus
qui démarre je ne veux pas aujourd'hui
présupposés de la fin des niveaux sans
l'aide une faute quand même mais je
pense que si nous en restons nous
aurions là ce serait une faute et je
pense que d'une manière générale il faut
sur ces sujets là écouter naturellement
les ministres et écouter aussi le
parlement mais par exemple
quand je vois que les crédits sont
coupés sur le ministère des affaires
étrangères en matière de coopération et
l'aide au développement
jeudi l'attention comment est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut lutter contre le
terrorisme par la guerre mais aussi par
le développement
si on n'aide pas un certain nombre de
pays à cibler je prends l'exemple de la
tunisie
vous avez deux millions de réfugiés
libyens qui sont en tunisie sur dix
millions d'habitants
si on n'aide pas la tunisie à se
développer il est clair qu'il ya là une
fragilité pour la tunisie mais aussi une
fragilité pour nous donc les crédits du
ministère des affaires étrangères sont
particulièrement importants dans cette
situation de guerre dans laquelle nous
sommes donc ce que nous souhaitons c'est
qu'il y ait des discussions avec le
parlement bien sûr d'abord entre les
ministres mais ensuite avec le parlement
pour le moment je ne peux pas crier à l'
incendie
quand il y a que quelques foyer
d'inquiétudes qui sont exécutés merci
beaucoup aussi bien française la suite
de l'épreuve de vérité avec marc réelle
de l'agencé france presse qui nous
rejoint
l'épreuve de vérité avec l'iphone
pour soi remarque bonsoir monsieur
raffarin pour soir alors ce soir on s'en
réjouit vous êtes avec nous le bureau
national des républicains se réunit vous
n'y êtes pas il doit statuer sur le cas
des membres du gouvernement issus du lr
soit aussi de le cas de député lr qui
soutiennent le gouvernement
vous n'aviez pas envie de participer un
tribunal non j'ai pas envie de
participer ni un tribunal ni à des
jugements de coupeurs de tête je crois
que clairement nous sommes dans une
crise qu'il faut regarder en face on a
perdu ses élections présidentielles
congre en partie de notre faute on avait
quand même un potentiel politique assez
incroyable un ancien prix en république
deux anciens premiers ministres une
jeune génération et tout ça avec nos
primaires avec notre organisation tout
ça nous a conduits à l'échec il faut
regarder cela en face et dans l'échec
pour mieux chercher à ouvrir qu'à
exclure
donc moi je ne suis pas pour les
exclusions je pense que aujourd'hui
personne ne peut se dire je suis
suffisamment fort pour dire que j'ai
raison que l'autre à tort
aujourd'hui il nous faut débattre
discuter nous respecter et personne ne
peut dire aujourd'hui que edouard
philippe
ce n'est pas quelqu'un de très bon
niveau de grande qualité comme c'est pas
la question et il fait toujours partie
de votre famille politique les mais est
ce que j'ai un terrain est ce que la
france a intérêt à ce que le système
macron dérive à gauche
est ce que pour nous qui sommes des gens
de la droite et du centre
nous avons intérêt à laisser la gauche
tout seul diriger le pays nous avons la
chance d'avoir un premier ministre et le
jour de carence est quelque chose que
nous demandions et il le décide donc
nous avons intérêt à avoir vis-à-vis de
ce premier ministre pour les plus
timorés du respect et pour les autres un
peu de sympathie voire d'affection dont
on peut être au gouvernement et est
membre de l heure ça ne pose pas de
problème moi moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas exclure des personnalités
qui sont des personnalités de la droite
et du centre qui représentent nos idées
et que ce n'est pas notre intérêt de
laisser le système dérivé à gauche
en tous les cas on va écouter eric
ciotti député et l'ère des
alpes-maritimes qui lui réclame une
clarification
moi je le souhaite comme beaucoup
aujourd'hui deux députés du groupe l'est
républicain comme la plupart des
militants notre ennemi politique que
ceux qui ont décidé de ne pas siéger
dans le groupe de notre famille
politique et il n'y en a qu'un sou neuf
fois ce plus partie de notre famille
pollution est ce que soit ils acquittent
soit ils soient au dessus
bien sûr dans la crise exclure est une
faute
qu'est-ce qui se passe nous avons perdu
des électeurs
où sont ils allés ses électeurs soit
dans l'abstention parce qu'on n'a pas
été assez attractif
soit elles sont allées dès le premier
tour voter manuel macron et donc il y a
beaucoup d'électeurs de droite et du
centre qui t'ont vote emmanuel macron
donc si on veut un jour rassembler notre
famille il faut parler à l'ensemble de
nos électeurs donc rejeté les uns rejeté
les autres ça conduit à toi à quoi ça
conduit a rétréci à chaque élection
notre espace politique et comme cela ça
va conduire à une stratégie d'une droite
dure d'une droite qui ne sera pas une
droite de rassemblement qui sera une
droite refermée sur elle même et ça ce
n'est pas bon je reste fidèle au pacte
fondateur de l'ump
c'est à dire le pacte qui anime les
républicains c'est à dire l'alliance de
la droite et du sang je suis pour le
respect des diversités et je ne suis pas
favorable aux exclusions que les uns ou
les autres puissent se mettre en congé
parce qu'à un moment ou un autre leur
situation serait pas compatible
c'est possible mais exclure c'est mettre
en cause l'idée de diversité qui doit
présider à une perspective de
rassemblement
est ce que les français n'attendent pas
de la cohérence justement ce vous nous
parlez de l'ump qui remonte quand même
en une quinzaine d'années et on voit
qu'aujourd'hui
aurait quand même peut-être une plus
grande cohérence à avoir un nouveau
parti comme on l'avait fait une époque
où le nouveau centre s'était créé sur
les ruines du modem est ce que les
constructif cette branche centriste de l
air ne devrait pas aujourd'hui créer un
nouveau mouvement
je pense que la droite gagne quand elle
est associée au centre j'ai entendu dans
la période récente que les élections se
gagnent est à droite
moi j'avais toujours appris avec valéry
giscard d'estaing qui est qui je suis né
en politique où les élections se gagnent
est au centre emmanuel macron pendant
que la gauche disait les élection se
gagne à gauche pendant que la droite se
disaient les élections se gagnent à
droite emmanuel macron a dit les
élections se gagnent au centre et c'est
lui qui a gagné
je pense qu'un nouveau cette règle d'or
s'est imposée et pour gagner au centre
il faut une alliance de la droite d'une
vraie droite mais d'un centre d'un vrai
sens
donc je pense qu'il faut reconnaître
cette diversité ces deux lignes
politiques différentes
c'est pas nouveau rené rémond a
longtemps expliqué que les bonapartistes
et les orléanistes constitué l'essentiel
de la droite française donc c'est pas
nouveau qui essaient de famille mais ces
deux familles doivent s'entend donc je
pense que il faut tout faire pour qu'on
puisse s'entendre donc je ne suis pas
nous faire prendre autant couper les
têtes mais que chacun respecte vous avez
dit tout à l'heure la diversité que vous
étiez inquiet de l'émergence d'une
droite dure 1 alors que on apprend que
l'élection du président de l air aura
lieu les 10 et 17 décembre et que là
manifestement c'est laurent wauquiez qui
est en piste
nous verrons est-ce que quelques pensez
vous de ces paires drake mi juillet les
deux familles dont vous parlez est ce
que vous le centre le soutiendriez lui
nous verrons nous verrons le paysage
politique du moment
moi je ne soutiendrai pas une approche
qui serait une approche exclusivement
droitière je suis pour une alliance de
la droite et du centre
et je ne vois pas comment on gagne dans
la république française sans une
alliance de la droite et du centre
donc je ne soutiendrai pas une démarche
qui conduirait à ce qu'il y ait une
indique alisation à droite du parti
auquel j'appartiens toujours mais tant
qu le carnet sai on a aujourd'hui un
côté wauquiez d'un côté solaire de 2
nous verrons nous verrons à l'intérieur
des républicains qui peut incarner ce
combat nous verrons comment les choses
peuvent se présenter
non mais là madame pécresse s'est retiré
et xavier bertrand aussi reste laurent
wauquiez
franchement soyons soyons tous prudents
à le jeu de lennon est un peu et un peu
modeste parce que quand on voit ce
comment on s'est tous trompés sur les
lésions résidentiel si l'élection dlr je
pense que pour moi l élection et l'air
elle est un peu anticipée je pense
qu'elle aurait été mieux si c'était un
peu plus tard parce que je crois
vraiment que on a des clarifications à
aborder et je crois que nos électeurs
veulent qu'on parle plus de la france
que de notre parti et ce qui compte
aujourd'hui si on fait de la politique
c'est pas la politique pour que notre
parti gagne c'est la politique pour que
la france réussisse et que on apporte
nos idées à la france et donc je crois
que on donne le sentiment on a fait des
primaires conduirait une dizaine de mois
et maintenant on repart dans une
élection partisane je crois qu'on est à
côté des préoccupations de l'opinion
publique donc ça ça me parait est une
erreur stratégique pour l'avenir une du
parti pour ce qui me concerne moi je
préfère faire en sorte que monsieur
macron quand il nous propose des choses
positives on le soutient et quand ils
proposent des choses avec lesquelles on
ce n'est pas d'accord on essaie de
corriger la copie d'accords rien il ya
un dîner qui a été très remarqué
quelques jours c'est celui des macros et
des sarkozy aujourd'hui on entend des
comparaisons on entend dire
macron sarkozy a des traits communs et
on prête à nicolas sarkozy ce mot de
dire que macron c'est moi en vous qui
les connaissaient finalement assez bien
tous les deux est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous pouvez valider ce serait
une première que nicolas puisse tout
vais mieux que lui laisse conclu mais il
un bon jugement vais en espèces mais je
trouve normal que deux hommes d'état
puissent se parler puisse discuter je
pense que quand on a des responsabilités
je me souviens avoir déjeuné avec manuel
valls a dit qu'il était installé à
matignon on échange dans l'intérêt du
pays je pense que sont des choses qui
sont utiles les responsabilités sont
tellement lourdes sont tellement
difficile que de parler avec quelqu'un
qui les a assumées ça éclaire sa salle
en force
celui qui est aux responsabilités donc
je pense vraiment que si cette
information est exacte
un dîner est prévu avec françois
hollande aussi bon et je pense que ce
sont des choses qui sont dans une bonne
démocratie utile et qu' il faut
respecter ce genre de contacts merci
beaucoup merci mr partie de l'épreuve de
vérité maintenant avec mikel ms de
public sénat qui nous rejoint
[Musique]
enfermé klc michel roussin jean pierre
raffarin dans 5 vous avez beaucoup parlé
des autres et bien bon moi j'ai
considéré que le temps était pour moi
celui de me retirer de la politique
élective je vais avoir 60 9 ans je pense
que c'est un âge raisonnable et puisque
nous sommes à une césure présidentielle
je pense que c'est le moment puisque les
jeunes prennent les rênes du pays de
leur laisser leur chance choc
générationnel
je pense qu'il ya aujourd'hui une sorte
de renouvellement des générations qui
s'installe et je pense que il faut
participer à ce mouvement il ya les bon
coeur et ne pas faire une résistance de
résister non non non je pense et ce à
deux depuis longtemps je pensais que
chacun peut voir ministre je ne donne
aucune leçon à quiconque mais je pensais
que le moment venez ou moi je voulais
partir de mes fonctions électorale en
pleine forme avec des projets et pas
partir programme justement est doucement
par la faiblesse gagnante mais au
contraire de partir quand les choses
vont bien en parlons de vos projets
laurine gelid aux sports pierre quand on
entend leader spears avait dit à ses
dirigeants mais met d'accord
qu'est ce que vous allez faire vous
allez devenir un lanceur n'alerte voilà
elle nous avons ce qui est frappant
aujourd'hui c'est que l'opinion publique
en france mais dans d autres pays n'a
pas conscience toujours de la gravité
des circonstances on n'a pas conscience
de la gravité de ce qui est en train de
se passer encore et on n'a pas
conscience de la gravité de ce qui se
passe à la frontière de la libye de la
tunisie pour prendre des exemples
ces deux exemples 1 nous montre bien que
finalement quand il ya une crise il ya
une forme d'émotion nationale ont
notamment en france en irlande et en
guerre et puis quinze jours trois
semaines après on oublie cette gravité
et on le voit encore quand il s'agit de
couper les budgets de la sécurité
donc ce que nous voulons c'est
construire une pédagogie de la crise et
donc d'expliquer à l'opinion publique
que sait que la crise de l'accord est ce
que c'est que la crise libyenne
et pourquoi c'est dangereux pour nous
tous et donc je vais demander à une
quinzaine vingtaine de leaders des
anciens premiers ministres des gens qui
ont eu l'habitude de ces dossiers et qui
savent par l opinion publique d'adresser
à l'opinion publique des messages sur la
prise de conscience de la gravité du
monde jean pierre raffarin si vous
permettez à faire un petit retour en
arrière du coup sûr votre carrière
politique si vous voulez bien est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire quel est votre
peut-être pire moment dans la vie
politique puis le meilleur aussi
commençons par le pire fiche on savait
il ya des mouvements moment très très
dur donc je ne peux pas les hiérarchiser
quand vous allez visiter le site d'un
centre et qu'est-ce qui vient de brûler
avec des enfants à l'intérieur pour rien
connaître de pire dans le but d des
événements quand vous êtes premier
ministre quand vous êtes élu
sur le terrain vous avez ce type
d'événement qui qui vous prennent à la
gorge et qui font que vous êtes face à
l'inacceptable incompréhensible c'est
sans les choses qui matignon c'était
vraiment l'enfer
matignon souhaite vraiment très
difficile à matignon une bonne nouvelle
ne dure pas plus d'une heure une heure
et demie tout de suite une mauvaise
nouvelle arrive donc à matignon la
pression est forte et il ya
naturellement des détentions en
permanence à traiter ce que j'avais
aussi des ministres de talent voire leur
place nicolas sarkozy dominique de
villepin et quelques autres ça ne
manquait pas de talent c'est le libre
donc le jeu les tenues trois ans mais
c'était quand même un travail petit
heureusement j'avais un président de la
république qui faisait grande confiance
à son premier ministre
et réciproquement on va écouter quelques
réactions de vos toujours collègues qui
s'exprime à votre sujet
moi je comptais beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup sur lui pour être un trait
d'union entre
toutes les tendances entre tous les
courants moi je suis pas sûr cela céline
positif je suis plutôt gaulliste mais je
considérais que si on voulait tous
restés à l'intérieur des républicains on
avait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup besoin
de gens comme quimper afin mais aussi
c'était quelqu'un qui parlait vrai
c'était quelqu'un qui manier l'humour et
on avait bien besoin aussi de ses petit
clin d'oeil qu'il nous faisait
régulièrement au delà bien évidemment du
rôle important qu'il a conduit pour
notre pays pour l'intérêt général pour
les françaises et premier français
moi je retiens de lui qu'il a toujours
voulu comme premier ministre comme
parlementaire lorsqu'il prenait des
positions le faire dans l'intérêt
général dans l'intérêt de la france est
d'un intérêt des françaises et des
français
c'est quelqu'un qui avait une haute idée
de la france et qui a servi son pays
c'est ça que j'aime moi dans les
responsables politiques de haut rang
alors de droite de gauche les réactions
unanimité assez c'est assez émouvant
quand je suis rentré de ces journées là
le soir chez moi j'ai dit à mon épouse
je rentre du cimetière et c'est très
rare qu'on rende du cimetière
donc j'ai très fort très franchement moi
je me sentais mieux merci et bien sûr
bassesse et je sais ma vie est donc le
respect des uns des autres comme que moi
j'ai respecté beaucoup de gens je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui vous prend
aux tripes donc mais aussi il faut
penser que d'un élève la vie politique
elle peut aussi être aujourd'hui est
nécessairement renouvelé je crois
vraiment qu'on est arrivé un peu au bout
d'une période
et quand on vous voyait la révolte qu'il
ya dans l'opinion sur le parlementarisme
sur un certain nombre de choses comme ça
donc il faut quand même se dire qu'il
faut trouver des recettes et je pense
que l'humanité progresse quand les
générations nouvelles trouve des
solutions aux problèmes que les
générations d'avant n'ont pas réussi à
vous je suis confiant dans l'avenir
pourquoi parce que je suis confiance
dans les jeunes les plus jeunes et qu'on
trouvera les solutions
j'ai confiance aux progrès j'ai
confiance en la science j'ai confiance
en la capacité de résoudre les problèmes
donc le fait de participer à ce que
un pays comme la france soit prise en
main par de jeunes générations on y met
des gens d'expérience c'est je crois
quelque chose d'important tout car je ne
voulais pas donner le sentiment
vis-à-vis de moi-même que je résistais à
ce mouvement et quand vous voyez j'étais
là en chine j'ai représenté le président
macron au forum qui a organisé le
président xi jinping sur la route de la
soie
il y avait là plus d'une trentaine de
chefs d'état quand je voyais comment il
parlait de la france cette france qui
s'est élevé contre la vague du populiste
contre la vague nationaliste contre la
vague du protectionnistes avec un jeune
président 39 ans j'étais quand même fier
de la france
et ça c'est très important et pour moi
c'est c'est ce que je mets au dessus de
tout et les visées par exemple n'y avais
jamais pensé même vos réseaux n'ont
jamais sage et j'ai jamais pensé c'était
une violence extrême les ege il y a dans
la fonction présidentielle quelque chose
qui est terrible c'est d'une certaine
manière la destruction de soi même vous
vivez avec une caricature vous vivez
avec quelqu'un qui est créé créé par
vous mais crée aussi par les autres par
les médias par les adversaires et donc
progressivement vous vous détruisez pour
créer quelqu'un d'autre secret qu'un
d'autres vous échappe en est donc c'est
quelque chose de terrible
et au fond et il ya là une violence
extrême parce que vous vous échapper de
vous même et c'est quelque chose que
j'ai compris très tôt et auquel je n'ai
jamais voulu toucher ne pas m'approcher
trop près du soleil parce que je sais
que là il ya un processus de de
destruction peut-être que dans ma
famille peut-être que j'ai été trop
heureux et que j'ai voulu protéger mon
bonheur maintenant que de me mettre en
risque comme d'autres se sont bien oui
mais je n'ai pas leur envie merci à vous
en tous les cas pour cette dernière
émission vous l'avez dit vous-même alors
que les journalistes on l'a évoqué
pendant cette émission les gens s
politiques sont souvent tenus à l'écart
en ce moment et bien on vous remercie
nous parce que vous avez toujours était
toujours disponible et très généreux
dans vos réponses et vous l'avez encore
démontré ce soir jean pierre raffarin
très bel été et on retrouvera pour la
suite de vos aventures merci qu'elle est
nous on se retrouve à la rentrée pour la
reprise de l'épreuve de vérité et sur un
public sénat avec l' agence
france-presse
c'est toujours bien sûr avec radio
classique et les échos très bel été
[Musique]